Oh, gosh.
Oh, maybe doing a karaoke was a mistake, but it's okay.
Whatever.
My throat will heal eventually one day.
Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Welcome.
Welcome to my sad karaoke.
Because that was fun?
Thank you!
I've seen many groups and concerts, mostly 80 bands with my dad.
I enjoyed all of them, but I enjoyed last night the most.
Thank you for being electric.
Really?
Stop.
Yeah, last night I had a...
A little event.
Kusa Land.
It was like an Anikura thing.
Oh my gosh.
SPTK is like, let's go!
Let's go!
Thanks for the 10 gifts!
Thank you so much!
I won't be able to watch this live, but thank you for your service.
Spreading the word of Denpagumi.
Can you tell us about your favorite members?
My Oshis.
Oshi is Ria P. Ria P. P.
Can't wait for more mincing.
I had a great time at Kusa Land.
You did awesome.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
So many people were there.
So cute.
I saw the picture of you guys.
So yeah, we gather here in honor of my favorite idol group of all time.
Who announced their disbandment yesterday.
Denpagumi Inc.
TV table tray.
Thank you for the 10 gifts and thank you!
Denpagumi Inc.
is like...
They have been my life force.
Maybe that's the reason why I'm a ghost.
Because I have to stick around.
I can't go to heaven.
Because I...
I can't move on.
Maybe I don't want to go to heaven.
I can't move on because I...
Because I just want to stay with Denpagumi.
I'm really hoping this doesn't affect Rito-kun too much.
She'll be around in Tokyo but I worry.
I think she'll be okay.
King Chrono!
Thank you for the 5 gifts!
I...
Uh...
Started as...
So...
Just to give you guys a background of some Denpagumi stuff.
Scorpio, thank you for the 10 gifts.
Um...
They came...
They come from a cafe in Akihabara called Deer Stage.
Which I love Deer Stage sooooo much!
Love Deer Stage sooooo much!
Which is a...
It's an idol cafe and bar.
And they do performances and stuff.
Almost daily.
And...
Um...
It's like...
Kind of legendary in Akihabara.
Especially because...
Um...
You know...
Denpagumi came from there.
And Denpagumi is...
Such a beloved idol group.
Like...
There are probably some idols that...
Would not be idols if it were for...
Weren't for Denpagumi.
Like...
I have pictures of Ano.
You know Ano from...
Uh...
She did the Chainsaw Man ending.
Kikikero kikikero kerochu.
She has...
She loves like Nemu...
Yumemi Nemu.
Which was my Oshii.
Um...
Like she has pictures with Nemu.
Like...
There are idols who...
Who...
Like...
Became...
Mini versions of Denpagumi members.
Um...
So they are trendsetters.
There are so much more than that!
They're like...
I don't know.
They've...
They...
They just have such an impact on the...
On...
Not just...
I wouldn't even just say the idol world.
I would say the...
Entertainment industry in Japan as a whole.
Have a fun stream Minto!
We'll definitely watch the VOD but now it's sleep before work.
Good luck with...
Work!
Um...
I wonder if Mint wouldn't be so Minty without Deerstage.
I don't think so.
Because...
Um...
My Oshii Yumemi Nemu...
She was the Mint member...
Of...
The group.
Kikikero kikikero kerochu.
She is the reason why I became...
To love the color Mint so much in general.
So...
I also like Nemukyun.
I love it!
Kamiyoshi...
My Kamiyoshi is Nemukyun.
Always Nemukyun.
Yeah.
So...
Um...
A lot of...
Even what I do...
Is always been influenced by Denpagumi.
And...
Um...
Just the way that I love idols...
And the way that I love Akihabara...
Has been influenced by Denpagumi.
So I truly...
I truly...
Like...
It's not an exaggeration...
When I say that I wouldn't be...
The ghost that I am...
Today...
If it wasn't for them.
So...
Um...
You know...
It's...
So awesome.
Moga is my Oshii.
Yeah...
Mogami Moga.
Um...
I know.
I get it.
They are super important to you.
Yeah.
They are like the most important to me ever.
And so...
Uh...
I know that we have...
Or I still have some time with them.
But...
I wanted to do this karaoke kind of early.
Because I was like...
Maybe if I get you guys into Denpagumi too...
Um...
If you...
Go to Japan...
And...
You have a chance to see them.
Maybe you'll be able to see them.
And...
Um...
I think...
Everybody should experience a Denpagumi concert.
At least once in their life.
It's so awesome.
Like...
Their fans are so great.
Um...
There's one member...
Furukawa Mirin.
Who...
Has...
Gotten...
I would...
I'm not gonna say infamous.
Because it's not that at all.
But she...
Uh...
Went...
She got...
She went viral...
For...
Being...
A...
Married...
Idol...
And she had a kid...
Uh...
Not so long ago.
Well...
How long ago?
A couple...
Maybe a couple years...
Two years ago?
Which is still...
That's still new.
That's still a new baby.
So...
Yeah...
Oh...
Hi...
I really love Denpagumi.
I'm so sad to see they're disbanding me too.
Like...
I have...
So many...
Like...
If I go into my closet...
Half of my t-shirts are Denpagumi.
Um...
I have like...
Happy Coats of Denpa.
I have...
I have a whole...
Like...
I only own one Ita bag.
And it's all Denpagumi themed.
So...
But...
Um...
We've had them around for a really long time.
16 years.
So...
Um...
Super duper grateful that...
And you know...
The sad truth of it is that...
In recent years...
They haven't been so popular.
Uh...
They started out as a group...
A duo...
This is like going way, way back.
But they started out as like...
Um...
You know...
As just...
Uh...
A duo.
And then they added more people in to be a five member group.
Which is what a lot of people...
Um...
Kind of...
I wouldn't say like the star...
But like...
The beginning of the star...
Of like...
The big Denpa era.
Um...
Then one of the members left.
Her name was Miyu.
And they added two other members.
Pinky...
And...
Moga.
Um...
And they became a group of six.
And um...
From there...
Like...
That was...
That was like...
The group...
That a lot of people really like...
Consider the golden era of Denpogumi.
Even though...
I love...
All of Denpogumi.
Mizutama Online OGs...
Yes!
They weren't even named Denpogumi at the time.
Um...
And they...
Were...
Created...
By...
Um...
Mofuku-chan.
Who...
Um...
Works at Deer Stage.
Which...
I don't know if anybody...
Recognizes them.
But if you do...
She actually...
Works as...
One of the...
J.P.
Staff...
In V-shojo.
So...
Um...
I remember when V-shojo announced that...
I was like...
Mofuku-chan?
No way!
So...
Yeah...
It's super...
So...
I...
It was like...
I was like...
No way.
Um...
This is...
There's no way.
Like...
So I was super duper shocked about that.
Is that so?
Yeah!
Yes!
So...
She technically works for...
Um...
V-shojo.
The world is so big and so small at the same time.
I know, right?
It was like the last thing...
I remember...
I...
Um...
I remember messaging...
A few of my friends who...
Uh...
They're not like super into...
Idol...
Not idols...
Um...
They're not super into Vtubers but they know Dempa and Deerstage and they were just like...
What?
What is this crossover?
But...
Um...
Mm...
And...
Uh...
So...
Um...
Uh...
What was it?
Um...
And that's not like secret news or anything.
They announced that.
But nobody...
I think people...
Didn't really know who she was.
So it kind of was like a...
Oh...
Some...
Some lady...
Joined...
Bishoujo Japan.
Yeah...
And so...
Um...
Yeah...
There was the Golden Era.
You have like the six of them.
They have songs that like...
Uh...
One thing that...
Or rather...
Here...
Let me finish my thought.
They have songs about like...
You know...
Being the six of them.
Things like that.
And...
Um...
One thing that like really makes them stand out from...
Uh...
Other idols is that they...
They're all like otaku girls.
Like...
They're all like...
You know...
Um...
It's so cute.
Mirin made a post...
Um...
She's like considered the leader.
She made a post...
Um...
Uh...
Recently...
You know...
Because of all of this.
Just being like...
I became an idol to...
To...
Like...
Get back at the people that said that I couldn't do it.
All the bullies.
Cause she...
Like...
She dropped out of high school and everything.
She...
Um...
And you know...
There was like...
It's just a...
It's like a kind of group of girls that you wouldn't...
Expect to be idols.
Who all...
Um...
Who all just became...
Shining stars.
And they're so sweet.
And so...
So great.
And...
I love all of them.
So...
Yeah.
Um...
So...
They're super duper awesome.
I only bought my...
My...
Um...
What's the word?
My...
Joy sound pass for...
For...
What?
For three hours.
And...
Denpugumi has many songs.
Um...
Not that I'm gonna sing all of them obviously.
Just...
You know...
Um...
The ones that I want to today.
Where the heck is...
Te...
Oh...
Uh...
Te...
I have my one Uchiwa that says Daisuki.
And my other Uchiwa that says Totoi.
Which means Daisuki, I love you.
And Totoi is like precious.
My precious group.
My favorite group ever.
Um...
So...
Let's see...
Um...
Where is my...
Oh there we go.
Den...
Um...
I think I'm gonna have to type in the group name every time.
Which kind of...
Sucks.
Because it's gonna take me a second.
Den...
Pa...
Gumi...
Ink...
I'm gonna start with a warm-up song.
Um...
Oh my gosh.
They have so...
The...
On Joy Sound here, they have 102 songs.
So...
Honestly...
I could...
Sing...
I think it's...
It feels like almost their whole discography.
Um...
They have so many.
And I'll be honest.
I'm probably going to sing more of the older songs.
Because...
Um...
Uh...
It's what I know best.
Um...
Uh...
By older, I mean like...
Um...
I don't know.
I don't know actually what is considered older anymore.
Um...
Future Diver.
I don't know if that's a warm-up song.
And I also apologize again about my voice.
Because...
Um...
I don't know.
I...
This...
Like I said.
Karaoke might be a mistake.
But...
Whatever.
I want to sing.
Denpa Gumi.
Um...
You're so freaking cute.
I can't deal.
What do you mean?
Um...
A lot of their songs are very like high energy.
There's like a whole genre called Denpa Music.
Which like...
Is very high energy.
Like...
Fun.
I don't even...
Like...
I'm bad at describing things.
But...
Um...
They're very high energy.
Akiba Pop.
They have lots of songs about Akiba.
They love Akiba too.
So...
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm going to sing this one.
Which is actually one of their more serious songs.
But...
I'm going to sing it to kind of warm up my throat a little bit.
I was just recording with Matara doing...
Um...
A...
For the podcast.
Um...
And we talked for...
Of course longer than we expected to.
So...
Um...
Yeah.
Actually...
No.
I'm going to save this one for later.
Because I will cry.
Okay.
This one is called Brand New World.
It is a bit more of a serious song.
But...
They have some pretty cool...
Actually...
No.
You know what?
I'm going to do Phantom of the Truth.
Because it is also...
It's a really cool song.
They did a...
Um...
They did a collab with a game called Phantom of the Kill.
Which I...
Uh...
Or no.
Phantom of Kill?
Anyway.
They were...
They were featured as characters in the game.
And this is the song from that.
And it's really cool.
And I...
Think it might be better...
Just try singing it than the other one.
Okay.
You know what?
I only have three hours.
That might pass.
And I started it at six.
So I already wasted twenty minutes, you guys.
Okay.
Let me know if the...
If the audio is okay.
I just killed the phantom Of my soul I just killed the phantom Of my heart I just killed the phantom Of myself I'm, I'm, I'm I'm the only one I just killed the phantom of my life
Oh my gosh, the timing is a little off.
Even if I make a small mistake, I will make everything stronger.
I will make a small mistake stronger.
I just killed the phantom of my heart.
I just killed the phantom of myself.
I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm the only one.
I'm just touching it.
I have the same intention.
I don't hesitate to do things like that.
Two things in one.
All
the sounds are fading away.
Your warmth won't reach me.
Yeah, warm up.
The flame in me is starting to burn.
Please stop my heart.
Going out of control now.
The words that won't disappear will always be there.
From that day on, you will always support me.
I don't know about this or that.
I keep repeating myself.
Go and meet the real me.
I will meet you someday.
Where will
I go after this?
No one knows.
I don't know.
I keep going around.
I don't care if I'm not the person I wanted to be.
I'm turning it into hope.
Now, I'm shouting in my heart.
The real me I call to the truth.
My heartbeat is getting hotter and hotter.
I'm hurt to live.
Even so, I keep moving forward.
I won't look away again.
I'll grab onto that hand.
I just killed the phantom of my heart.
I just killed the phantom...
Yay!
That was Phantom of the Kill.
Which is such a cool song and I just murdered it.
But that's okay.
Phantom of the...
The...
Kill...
Oh, no.
Truth.
Sorry.
I was mixing up.
Truth.
Phantom of the Truth.
Oh, it just totally went off.
Hold on.
There we go.
Yeah, warming up.
I think I put it in the pinned message.
But in case you're watching this later, I'm not going to do well on a lot of these songs.
Because a lot of them are made for six people.
And also...
Their range is like...
They can go from like very cool voices to very like cutesy and like...
And...
It doesn't...
It might not suit my voice entirely.
But we're just here to have fun.
So hopefully you like the songs.
And...
You just check them out yourself.
Because...
They have some...
They have such an incredible...
Oh, sorry.
Hold on.
I'm typing at the same time.
They have an incredible...
Discography.
They have so many different types of music.
Starting off good.
Time to clone yourself.
Yeah.
This next song, I know I can sing.
But it also makes me cry.
So...
My performance is about passion.
Not studio recording precision.
Okay.
Passion.
Yeah.
This one though.
I think I can do.
This song.
This next one.
I might sing again later.
Because I just love it so much.
It might be actually my favorite Denpogumi song.
And I sing it every time I go to karaoke.
I sing a lot of their songs every time I go to karaoke.
I say a lot, but I'm not very...
Well, I do sing them, just not very well.
So, next one!
It's a slower song.
We did a cool song, now we'll do a slower song.
I'm gonna have to go get some more tea soon.
I'm waiting for my... I was waiting for my water to load.
Not load.
Boil.
I'm waiting for my water to load.
A little pause... and we are back.
This song has me blushing!
That
was Kuchitsuke Kibonu.
One of my favorite songs.
Actually, ever probably.
Let's see.
It's like kind of weird.
Kuchitsuke Kibonu.
Like that.
That was so cute.
I didn't know it was a Denpokumi song.
Yeah!
It's so awesome.
Let me see.
If I click this and... well, let me search Denpokumi.
Oh, I can put them under my favorite artist.
Wait, how do I search my favorite artist though?
Is there like a way?
Hmm...
This is ranking...
Sorry, I'm using Joyce.
Oh wait, maybe here.
Maybe under my name.
I can put them under my favorite but I can't search it?
Hmm... kind of weird.
Even when they're gone, they're still the ones you love.
Yeah.
So true.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
My room may be under here.
Oh, yes!
Okay, perfect.
Now I don't have to type them in every time.
I'm using tilt controls!
Oh my gosh, I don't know what else is... there's so many songs.
I'm just gonna go through and...
There's a lot of these though that I feel like I can sing...
better than other ones.
I think I'll just...
cry the whole time.
They have so many good like feel-good songs.
Actually, maybe I'll do this one.
Hold on...
I'm not... like a lot of these I've never sung before so it's...
I kind of always stick to the same ones but that's okay.
Wait, what's actually... no, I can't sing some of these because I'll just cry!
Okay, let's get through some of these without crying.
Orange Reum!
That's one of them!
I'll just cry!
I'll just cry.
WWD Best.
This one though, I tried... actually I sang this one at karaoke.
I tried singing it... last time I was in Japan.
I don't know if you guys noticed but in the lyrics of Kuchitsuke Kibo, which is the short name of Kuchitsuke Kibo.
They talk about... they sing about being an akiba and everything.
And this one... this song is also about akiba.
But I think if I sing it, I...
Okay, we gotta try it.
We just gotta get through this.
No, I'm gonna save it for later.
I can't, I can't, I can't.
I'm already tearing up.
I can already feel myself tearing up.
Do they have a WWD?
I feel like they should, right?
Oh, they do!
So, they have two songs.
WWD...
WWD 2.
And then WWD Best.
Which is the first one.
WWD is kind of like about how the girls met.
It's about how the lyrics are like...
We're starting from this small stage but one day we'll reach the world.
Oh, I forgot to do the intro.
Oh my gosh, I went to do this when I first started the stream.
Moe-kyun song wo sekai ni o todoke!
Denpagumi Incu desu!
Yoroshiku onegaishimasu!
So this is their like little catchphrase that they say.
That means basically spreading...
We're Denpagumi!
We're spreading Moe song... Moe-kyun songs all over the world!
And they do like this little thing with their hands and then they make their...
They make like an L shape with their hands and then they...
Put it above their heads.
Yeah.
Sorry, I guess maybe I should show you guys what songs I'm looking at, right?
No, maybe it's better to...
Keep it secret.
I don't know.
But yeah, WWD is about like how they came to be.
WWD 2 is like a little more dramatic.
It's about like how each girl kind of doubts themselves.
But together as Denpagumi, they are so powerful and great.
And then WWD Best was the last...
Version of the song.
And that was right before...
The member MOGA.
She left from the six that I talked about earlier.
Cryingwugfan.com Yeah.
And...
So...
You know...
After MOGA left...
Because you know, you have WWD, you have WWD 2.
In the songs, they like...
Mention each other's names.
After MOGA left, they kind of weren't really able to perform these songs anymore.
They eventually did get two other members.
Nemotonagi.
Who is also a member of another idol group I really like.
Nijin no Konkistador.
And Perorin.
She was...
She's an artist.
She does a lot of like...
Idol...
Otaku art and stuff like that.
And...
Not Botchinatsu is my fave.
Nemu is so cute.
I know!
Oh my gosh, I love the...
I love the remixes of it.
I listen to them...
Quite often.
They're fun.
But yeah, so they added them.
After that...
The group...
After...
They were added, they were...
A group of...
What?
Seven.
Se...
Seven people for a while.
Then, Mai Kami Oshi...
Um...
Yumemi Nemu.
She announced graduation.
And then...
Um...
Not so long after that...
Another member...
Eitaso...
Um...
Naruse Eimi.
Her nickname is Eitaso.
She...
Announced graduation.
Um...
You might recognize her because she...
Actually voiced a...
A Precure.
Um...
Which was one of her dreams.
And it came true.
I'm so happy for her!
Um...
But uh...
After that...
Um...
They added a bunch of new people.
Uh...
And...
Um...
The group kind of...
Became a little bit more turbulent.
Um...
With more...
More and more members leaving.
Um...
Uh...
So...
It's understandable that...
Um...
That...
You know...
They're ending...
Especially with some of the...
Core members also...
Uh...
Also...
You know...
Getting older...
And...
Starting families even.
So...
Hmm...
Um...
But...
They've always been...
So awesome.
I'm gonna try singing WWD too.
But...
You're going to quickly realize why this song is very difficult to sing.
Especially...
As...
One person.
And...
It also has different languages in it.
So...
Um...
Uh...
If I get them wrong...
Sorry.
Okay.
Actually, you know what?
Hold on.
I'm gonna show the screen for this one.
Wait.
Where is it?
Here we go.
Bonjour!
Nosume!
Denpa-gumi!
Inc!
Coup d'hoteur!
Idol!
Japanese!
Chin!
Song!
In!
Japan!
Akihabara!
To!
All over the world!
Form!
Record!
Cin!
Film!
Ah!
Yosha!
Ikuzo!
Mirin!
Nisa!
Nemu!
Ei!
Moga Pinky!
Denpa-gumi!
That's all the different members!
Injimerare!
Heya ni hikikometeita!
Keisen dake ga watashi ga imasho datta!
Yume yabure yabure yabure ni natte ta!
Futto kizuitara koko de waratteta!
Radio dake ga tomodachi datta!
Chuunibyou hidoku de minna iteta!
Douga saito takusan odotte!
Te mita yo!
Saisei!
Sono tame!
Pasokon ga jiri tsuite ta!
Anime!
Manga!
Inaka de!
Akogareteita!
Seiichi!
Akiba!
Watashi!
Koko de ikite masu!
Zutto zutto hikikomote nettoge yateta!
Ryou te ja tarinai kara!
Ban-chon!
Chi!
Ki!
Ashite!
Osu!
Shiteita!
Nanmonai watashira datte!
Dekai yume mezashite tenda!
Boku shitein da!
Kekko!
Sanai!
Dororo!
Doko!
Dodo!
Den!
Kanai!
Kubiri no denpa!
Doko mademo yukeru!
Suteru no nan katai!
Minasu kara no!
Stato!
Namen da!
Kyou!
Dotan!
Botan!
Kito deki wo!
Six!
Shinkashi teiku!
Uchiran no stailu de!
Kachi toru yo!
Denka!
Ikiru basho nante!
Doko ni mo nakatta nta!
Ima wa yume no tame ni!
Tsuyoku!
Hanate!
Tte!
Let me tell you how to use .
Please shout it twice after our singing.
Five, four, three, two, one, go!
Japan, America, Italy   France, Spain, Taiwan   Brazil, China, Singapore   Worldwide
!
...
A little pause... and we are back.
A little pause...
and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
Yeah!
My voice is like...
My voice is like... not suited to sing this right now but it's okay.
That was WWD.
Next!
Of course we have to do...
Of course we have to do... WWD 2!
WWD 2!
That song is so crazy.
That song is the best song ever.
Makes me feel so emotional.
I mean maybe for people who don't...
know Dempa so well.
But you can kind of feel the passion from it, right?
And that's why Dempa Gumi was so powerful.
And amazing.
Just kind of like...
You had this group of girls who were like...
I was depressed.
I didn't know what I was doing with my life.
I only...
kind of realized the reason I was born.
Because of...
Because of you know...
doing this.
They found their passion and their calling.
WWD 2!
Oh I should get more tea after this song.
Don't let me forget.
But wait if I do...
up to date.
die.
I
won't go.
That was my goal.
I am chapter two.
After.
number.
One done.
So.
I don't know this one as well.
I'm sorry to cry.
Is it necessary for me?
Shut up!
Stop it already!
Why are you all running around?
I don't care if it's just a date.
I don't care if it's just a fight.
I don't want to run away anymore.
Because there are only six of us.
I'm sure, I'm sure that no one will lose.
I'm not being cocky.
I don't want to face people and the test.
I don't want to, I don't want to, I don't want to.
I don't care.
But now it's 1 for all.
All for one.
I can't stop here.
The red line is sticking out.
But I'm not confident.
I'm not being cocky.
White line.
Why can't I say anything?
I have to be more firm.
Yellow, I want to shine on everyone.
But it's all in the past.
Oh my god, my...
I can't notice the tip of my boat.
Why can't I notice it?
Blue alone.
I'm overflowing with tears.
Well...
Sorry, my voice is so bad.
Oh, people rated.
Hello, thank you.
I'm singing badly today.
1 for all.
All for one.
All for you.
1 for all.
All for fans.
All for dream.
1 for all.
It's
okay if it's a good thing.
It's okay if it's a bad thing.
I'm alone for everyone.
Everyone is for one person.
And let's send love all over the world.
Ah, let's go.
Meaning.
Lisa.
That was W.
W...
Oh, D.
2.
And the part in the middle when they're just like...
I wonder if it's necessary.
It's like each girl says it one at a time.
And all the fans are just like...
Because, you know, they're basically saying...
Am I...
Am I needed?
You know, like, am I...
Am I important?
And everyone's like...
Yeah, you're so important.
Yeah.
Did you see us yelling?
I did.
Yeah.
So they're all just like...
It's a song about being just kind of like...
Oh, I realized also earlier.
I think I said meeting was the leader, but she's the center.
Risa is the white member.
She's the leader.
So I...
I meant...
I'm in my brain.
I knew center, but I said leader on accident.
But yeah.
So...
So, yeah, like, they're all just kind of talking about how they don't have any confidence.
And they are just like...
We don't...
We don't know if we're doing a good job.
But with us together, we're doing a good job.
And we can, you know, we can spread our Dempa power all over the world.
Get that tea.
I will.
I'll be right back.
Let me go get my tea.
My...
I'm so sorry for my throat.
I can't do high notes at all right now.
I probably...
Like I said, I know I keep repeating myself.
I shouldn't be doing this karaoke, but I don't care.
I don't care.
Okay.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Oh, I should have gotten a spoon.
I should have gotten a spoon.
I have, like, this...
You know, like, the...
The, like, honey loquat stuff?
That's really good for your throat.
I forgot I had that.
But I'm drinking throat tea right now.
So...
You know what?
Maybe I can just suck on this.
Where's the opening?
It would help if I could.
I totally forgot I took these fans out of my hand.
But I'm also...
A ghost.
Mmmmm.
Yummy.
Okay.
Oh...
Oh, there we go.
All right.
I don't know if I can do WWB.
Or WWD-Best right now.
I don't know if I can do it.
A lot of these songs will just make me cry.
I don't know.
Thank you very much!
Thank you!
Also, tell me if you prefer seeing the lyrics or not.
A little pause... and we are back.
Wait, is that the part where it goes, Honto?
Dayo ne?
Or is it, Honto dayo ne?
Can't remember.
La la la, la la la la la la.
Shibuya!
Yane wo hasiru konoko no you ni boku wa kiseki wo matte ita yoru Wa bura tsuki aruiteita Subete o hiraku kagi ga mitsukaru Sonna hi wo sagashiteita kedo Nante tanjun de baka na ore Ah, machi wa fukaku Bokura wo itaku
Tsuyoi kimochi Tsuyoi ai
Wait, they say this part over.
Stand up, dance, and dance in the middle of joy.
Dance in the middle of
joy.
Dance in the street, baby, yeah!
It's under the skyscraper building that was lit up warmly.
Look, it's dawn in a blink of an eye.
Beautiful sky, echoing blue sky.
Days that no one has ever seen.
I hold them tight in my chest.
I want to engrave them in my heart.
Ah, the city is deep.
I want to walk.
Strong feelings.
Strong love.
My heart is also tightly connected.
Many sorrows remain.
We offer each other.
These feelings right now.
Strongly, strongly, strongly.
The evening sun rises.
Days of life are going on.
A big, deep river passes between you and me.
As the tears fall, I keep sping my cheeks.
A strong wind has become cold.
You and I laugh.
These feelings right now.
It's true, isn't it?
A little pause... and we are back.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry if you're finding out from me.
I'm so sorry.
It's okay.
You can do this again when it's better.
Yeah, exactly.
I think I can maybe do this one if I...
This song I might have to put on... like get Romaji lyrics for, for real.
I want to do Precious Summer, Evergreen.
I might cry at this one.
Today's fandom are Mintogumi.
Yeah!
I'm so happy to hear Mintogumi singing.
Thank you!
I'm happy too.
Precious Summer kills me so much.
Me too.
Precious Summer.
This is our last summer with Denpa.
Oh gosh, I can't.
I can't think about it.
I can't think about it too much.
I just have to think about me having...
I just have to think about me...
Just thinking about this as a normal karaoke stream.
Okay, Future Diver.
This is like probably I would say their most popular song.
The calls in it are so much fun.
I recommend 100% looking up a video of them performing it.
So you could see.
Just how much fun the whole thing is.
It's so awesome.
Yeah.
It's Mintogumi's turn.
But this song is also very hard.
So I'm not going to sing it well.
Just a warning.
Let's go!
Diver, Dermagumi Inc's Future Diver!
Maji bye bye bye don't need diver Ko Kyu Shinpai nai yo Maji koi koi koi Future Diver Oyo kimashou Wasurete nakunai kai Tanoshibyou ga muremuya Jotto gurai shinkashite Kaseki wa yada yo Nan demo ariranda Samishibou ni narinare
A little pause... and we are back.
A little pause...
and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
Yes!
If you say Yes!
Say Yes!
Dive!
If you say Yes!
Say Yes!
Dive!
Into me!
Into you!
Dive!
Into me!
Into you!
Dive!
Dive dive dive dive dive dive dive!
Dreams won't end.
Yes!
Your future-time is full of dreams.
Swim into it.
Yo yo yo yo yo yo yo yo!
No!
You can't!
A little pause...
and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
Here we go.
I started reaching for my tea, so I like...
So I completely forgot.
During like the beginning parts, when it's like...
The calls you do are just like...
You say the member's name, so it's like...
Miri no mabushi ni hayo hai!
I actually, I'll be honest, I don't know the calls for the new girls.
Because I don't know...
I don't know who sings which part anymore.
I just remember the original.
I like how many switch ups they have in their songs, it's fun.
Yes!
That's one thing about them, is that they are just...
Their energy is unmatched.
Their songs like, take you on a journey.
It's so fun.
You can tell they are hard.
You are doing great.
Thank you!
I'll have to do a revengeance when I'm...
When my throat is eventually healed.
This will be my last karaoke for a long time.
Yeah, let's do one that's not so straining for me right now.
Um...
There was...
What was I...
There was one song.
I think...
Did I...
Oh wait, I forgot to add it.
Sorry, my bad.
Future Diver.
Um...
This song is...
It's not her graduation song.
Actually, Evergreen, I believe, is what she said would be her graduation song.
But my kami oshi yume minemu...
When she sings this song...
At her final live.
I kind of, in my heart, consider this as her graduation song.
Sorry Nemu.
Even though whatever my Oshii says is justice.
Take care of yourself, I understand.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But this one, I think, is just very special to me.
So I'm going to try and sing it.
Yeah.
I hope I don't.
Oh my gosh, I've never sung this before.
I've never sung this before because I always thought that I would just cry.
Now I just know that I can't sing it.
Everyone loves me.
I guess I'm going to try to sing over right now.
She's actually really focused in singing that part.
easiest part, she's even more!
Sver rimerik.
Maybe they thought you'd sing it already?
Send her status so proof of that!
I'm showing you that I'm a virgin!
Maybe she knew this was aanger.
Come on girl!
Girl, high five!
Yay!
Hold
on, let me respond to...
Okay.
Okay, that was...
One second, okay.
Did you sing Sakura Operation already?
I have not, because it's not on the setlist yet.
Or rather...
It's not written, so I have not sung it yet.
Welcome though, welcome.
This song made me so happy.
It's such a sweet song.
It's so cute.
Like I said, I can't sing a lot of their songs well.
Because I mostly just listen to them.
But...
But yeah.
They have such cute songs.
And fun songs.
Do I...
I'm gonna try singing this one.
It's kind of another...
They have a bunch of really fun songs.
Chururi, chururira.
I won't be singing because...
It's...
So fast.
Then Parade maybe I can do.
Sabotage!
Notobochi.
Minto being a part of the idol group too.
They just don't know it yet.
I...
It's funny because like...
I mean, if you had asked me...
Years ago...
If I wanted to be an idol...
I think...
No, not I think.
I know.
100% I would have been like...
Yes, yes!
I want to be an idol!
But...
I don't know so much now.
I almost wanted to say...
If you wanted to die, try...
Chururi, chururira.
But LOL.
I don't know so much now.
If I want to be an idol...
Um...
I think that...
One thing I...
One thing that...
You know...
There's one...
Obviously...
Hold on.
Let me gather my words.
When you...
Are a fan of something...
It can be natural to...
Also want to be a part of that thing, you know?
Like...
You know...
If you want to...
If you're a fan of idols...
You want to be an idol.
Um...
But to me...
I think...
Um...
You should...
Honestly...
If you have those feelings as well...
You should...
Cherish the feeling of being a fan more.
Because...
You know...
Say you...
Join...
Become...
What you love...
And be...
Say that...
What you love...
Is not what you expected...
And...
You know...
What you...
The thing...
You know...
Maybe things are...
Not as...
Good as you thought it would be...
Maybe...
You join an idol group and...
Um...
You're just like...
Hold on...
Oh...
I loved...
I loved seeing...
My favorite idols...
Um...
Being so cute together on stage...
I bet they're the bestest of friends...
And then you join...
And...
Maybe they...
They don't like each other...
Maybe they don't talk...
Maybe it's just the complete opposite of what you imagined...
Maybe...
The manager is...
Like...
A...
Poopy guy...
Maybe...
Um...
Just...
You know...
Once you learn...
The...
Ends of something...
Um...
It's...
You know...
If you...
It's much harder to...
Uh...
Go back to being a fan...
And you'll never have that opportunity again...
I'm not...
Usually one to say...
Don't meet your heroes...
Because every time I've met my hero...
I've...
You know...
Been very happy...
But...
But you'll never have that opportunity...
You'll never have that love again...
If...
The thing that you...
Loved...
Once...
You know...
Turns into resentment...
You can never...
You can never take that back...
So please cherish being a fan...
If you can...
You know?
So...
That's all I...
Wanted to say about that...
Let's see...
Um...
Oh...
I was gonna do this one before...
But I can do it now...
Actually...
Oh...
I'm sorry...
I was gonna say...
I was gonna...
Do a couple other songs...
From that album...
But...
Like...
There were some songs...
That like...
From Denpa...
That really...
Like...
When I was so down...
They really saved me...
So...
I...
I don't think I can sing them at all though...
Because I...
Definitely...
Will cry...
What?
Is this a hit song medley?
Like...
This is one of them...
This is one of the songs...
And this one...
Kibono...
Uh...
Let's see...
But we can do Brand New World...
This one's a little bit more serious...
So...
A little cooler...
More simply...
I feel like people don't need to turn their hobbies into a career...
Sometimes...
Just having the hobby to yourself is more satisfying...
Yeah...
Of course...
I mean...
There's always the what ifs...
But...
I mean...
What if you...
What if...
What if it ruins the whole experience for you?
That's the part that scares me the most...
What if...
If I ever throw away my love...
That's the only reason that I can do it...
One more time...
Please don't leave...
It was reallyiser than I thought...
I feel like I'm playing Groove Coaster with this background...
Haha!
Hear the music...
The same vitamin Q effect...
To be smooth...
Hold these wirklich clarinas...
Let's see what else...
What kind of future did you aim for?
The drawing of a dream is certainly here.
I'm so anxious that I can't go back to those days.
The spiral of my heart is falling.
We are running aimlessly.
Seeking the light of dawn.
Because the sky has always continued.
I can't help but cry.
I said goodbye to you.
I was scared.
Will we ever become stronger than now?
I was waiting all the time.
Just looking.
What kind of wish did you make?
A little pause... and we are back.
A little
pause...
and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
A little
pause...
and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
An hour and a half...
Oh!
My brain kept thinking two hours.
Oh my gosh, you're right.
You're right.
I kept thinking...
For some reason, I was like, oh my gosh.
I only have until eight.
I'll never forget what it felt like to scream the word bust.
It makes me feel good at my oshi in a room full of wits.
I'll cherish yesterday.
Thank you for being there.
Thank you, Ray.
That's so awesome.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for the 50 gifted.
Well, I might...
For... What's that?
Nine?
The pass on my...
I only got a JoySound pass for three hours.
So, I won't be able to...
I won't be able to sing anymore.
Unless I pay for like another hour.
Which I don't know if I have enough.
I might have to buy another card.
Oh!
No, no, no.
Go away.
Yeah, yeah.
So, it's not that I have anything.
Maybe I will try Sakura.
Apparition.
Even though I don't think I'm gonna be able to sing this song very well.
I will try Sakura Apparition.
The music video for this one is maybe my favorite Dempa music video.
It's so...
The way that it's made is so cute.
It's so fun.
It's just...
It's so creative.
I love it.
Hey, Ren.
Thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you.
Hey, yo.
T E M P A from...
Is PURPLE Bay Area!
You'll see a lot of their songs always talk about Akihabara, but it's so great.
I love Sakura Apparition.
I love their songs, too!
Meh, Meh, Meh...
Yeah!
Hey, yo!
T E M P A from Akihabara to everywhere!
.
Mu And we don't love anything anymore.
Ay .
And sweet things!
an  ne We are back from last year's soccer game.
A little pause...
and we are back.
They are like singing over each other in this song.
It's so fast.
When they perform this song, they sometimes have, like, sakura petals coming from the stage and everything.
And we all have this same dance move.
It's so cool!
I'm
very excited!
Throat can reach that note right now.
Oh, whoops, wrong way.
There we go.
Bye bye sa- Maybe I should have said that for last, right?
Bye bye sayonara sakura appellation.
Definitely check out the music video for that one.
It's such a- Their songs are just so fun!
Like, their shows are just a whole big party.
It's so great.
They're the bestest girls ever.
I do wonder how Churururururu would be like.
Also, this one's really great too.
I've never sung it.
A lot of these, like I said, I've never sung before.
But...
If they played that at their last show ever, I think they will.
It's one of their really popular songs.
What album do you recommend?
They have like a WWD best album.
Which has a lot of their popular- It doesn't have any- It doesn't have anything of their newest stuff, but it does have like their older, classic stuff.
Have you seen them live often?
Not often.
I've seen them...
I can count how many times I've seen them live on one hand, probably.
When I liked them at my peak, I couldn't afford to go see them very often.
So...
Um...
Uh...
And...
Even still, it sometimes can be difficult to see them because of, uh...
Because sometimes like I can't get- Not that the tickets are selling out, but it's like hard to get them as like a foreigner, you know?
What app are you using?
Is it on the Switch?
Yes, it's on the Switch!
It's called the JoySound app.
You have to, um...
You have to have a Japanese account to get it though.
What's the other one?
Not...
Maybe they don't have it...
Wait...
This one would make me cry.
I wonder how the medley is like.
I love Kita Kita Ne.
I love...
I love all their songs.
There's like not a song that...
Oh, Akihabara-ife!
This one is really fun because the music video is in Akihabara.
I have to do WWD best at some point.
Actually, this one is also Akihabara song.
This one is like a really slow song.
It's probably the slowest song they have.
But it's really pretty.
In fact, I will sing it.
I will sing it.
They only release bangers.
And they do, they do.
I'll sing Sabotage, don't worry.
You don't have to pay me anything.
I'll sing it.
"'Ketsuhito uwaari ga kita ra' Kitto hawa no mashiho de saigo ni
Uranai wo yakusoku shiyou Suki, kirai, suki..."
Sorry!
A little pause... and we are back.
A little pause...
and we are back.
Oh my gosh.
Sorry guys.
Maybe too early to sing that one.
Aki... Aki no... wait.
Ha... no... hara... pa... de.
It's kind of a... is it the other day?
I'm not sure.
Wait, let me double check it.
Aki no hara no hara pa de.
I haven't even gotten to the songs guys that will make me cry the most.
I haven't even gotten to the songs that will make me cry the most.
I haven't even touched Orange Room.
Or Kirakirachun.
Oh gosh.
No...
Oh...
Yeah, okay.
Oh no.
Oh no, okay.
Let's do...
Let's do Den Den Passion.
This one is also one that I'm going to mess up a lot.
But, that's okay.
Actually, maybe I can get...
Maybe I can get Aromaji for this one.
Because I don't know otherwise if I'll be able to sing it.
But I really just up -de  if I do get My
reading comprehension.
My reading comprehension.
Okay.
The song is also Okay.
The song is also a super duper popular song.
A super duper popular song.
When they do the dance for this...
They use ribbons.
And it's so fun!
It like, they're spinning the ribbons all around.
They even do Otagei with the ribbons And it's so much fun!
And it's so much fun!
I actually know it.
I learned this dance.
Maybe one day I can show you guys if I ever have a 3D model.
Oh!
There's MoFuku-chan!
Who I mentioned earlier.
Oh!
My voice!
My throat!
I wonder if I'll be okay in the future.
It's a tough world, isn't it?
That's why I said this.
It's okay!
Everyone is gay and we're friends!
Eita-san is doing well.
Oh!
It's about to start!
Hey yo!
Tempo check 1, 2!
It's about to start!
In the middle of a story!
In the middle of the world!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Keep moving forward!
Oh!
Let's get crazy!
Let's go crazy, crazy, crazy!
I'll do something!
La la la la la!
Yuki of the world!
Da
da da da da da da da!
Da da da da da...
No matter how much tea I drink my throat will never be prepared for that song!
That was
like...
That was like Den-Den Passionless.
I'm going to take more of this honey stuff.
You guys, I've been drinking this whole stream.
It's just that I got sick.
And it kind of messed up my throat.
And it hasn't fully recovered.
So...
But also...
Don't tell me I'm not doing this.
Tell me what to do.
I don't need a bunch of people being like...
Stop streaming!
Don't sing anymore!
I know my limits.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, don't worry.
Right now I'm eating honey.
It's like a...
It's like a special honey throat thingy.
Also, that song was just crazy.
You can't breathe in it.
So I'm like trying to keep up.
Again, songs meant for six people.
My
throat...
And I know it sounds painful when I sing.
But my throat doesn't hurt.
It's just like raspy.
It doesn't hurt me at all.
It just can't hit the notes.
So it's not like I'm hurting myself.
Or anything like that.
If you're just like, oh my god.
No.
It just isn't hitting the notes.
As well.
Yeah.
Let's see.
But I still have an hour.
It's another song that I can do.
Maybe...
There's the other one though.
Hold on.
I'm gonna look it up.
Tempagumi.
Tempagumi ink.
Don't forget there's the ink at the end of their name.
It's one of the song lyrics even.
They're like...
Don't forget the ink at the end of our name.
I wonder if I could sing...
Baby, baby.
That one part at the end of Precious Summer.
Na, na, na, na.
Baby, baby.
Oh, I got it.
Honey, money.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you very much.
Maybe, maybe.
Na, na, na, na, na.
Actually, there is a song in here that I do want to sing.
Which I think I saw towards the top.
And I was like, oh my god.
They have this on here.
I saw it.
Hold on.
Oh, wait.
Is this the one that I want to...
Hold on.
I don't know.
I feel like I'm losing my brain.
Hmm.
Otsukaresama.
That's another fun song.
Because they use towels in the dance.
Na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na.
That one is also the rap part.
I'll screw it up so bad.
Can't get it at all.
Oh, also, you guys may have heard Denpogumi before and didn't even realize.
If you...
Um...
Watch Saiki-ken.
Okay, they did the openings.
The opening songs.
Yeah, so...
They did those songs.
Wait, where was it?
Oh, wait.
No.
Wait.
Hmm.
I know I saw it under here though.
I think actually...
I think I need to search the keyword.
Not artist.
Yes.
Because there's even more songs under searching as a keyword.
There's so many Denpa songs.
I mean, they've been around for 16 years, so...
Of course there's gonna be a ton.
I wonder if they have any of the old, old ones.
Thank you!
Thanks, Volge.
I wonder if they have anyone's like magic mirror on here.
No, but the magic of the magic will be beautiful.
That's the secret magic of the mirror.
Also!
One of the members, Aizawa Risa.
She is in another group called...
Oh my gosh.
She's in a duo.
Someone help me, please.
But in the duo, they did the endings for...
Lavaleth!
Yes, thank you.
Thank you, Thomas.
My brain kept saying Mia Regina, and I was like, that's not it.
That's not correct.
She's in a... yes, Lavaleth.
They did the endings for the Aqua Taupe anime.
So...
Denpa is everywhere.
Here we go.
So this song is not specifically a Denpa Gumi song, but it is sung by my favorite...
It's sung by my Kamiyoshi.
Yumemi Nemu.
And...
It's actually one of the songs from her album.
Her graduation album.
So...
I will try and sing it.
I've never sung this one before either.
Oh my gosh.
I hope I do it justice for my Oshii.
I didn't get to go to her graduation, but there was a...
She did like a solo show.
Well...
It wasn't a solo show.
It was like a...
She did like a celebration show.
And I got to go see her there one more time.
But I only got to see her twice, believe it or not.
The name of the song is called This is called my last love song.
A little pause...
and we are back.
A
little pause...
and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
This is called my last love song.
You'll hear...
Nemo has this really awesome version of it.
That actually was remixed by one of my favorite music producers ever, Panda Boy.
I always remember it by the Japanese name because I'm a weeb, sorry.
So...
It's super...
They played that in arcades when I was there.
I assumed it was to make you sleepy and want to leave.
Yeah.
It's just...
I don't know why they play it when things are ending.
But it's like kind of...
It's like bittersweet, you know?
You hear it and you're just like, Aw, that was so fun.
It's too bad that it has to end.
I don't think they have it on here though.
Especially Nemo's version because...
Actually, let me search.
You met me, Nemo?
Because there's a rap part in it.
And I've always wanted to try it.
I've never been...
I've never...
I've never been able to sing it.
Met me.
Net.
Oh!
I
don't know.
Actually, I...
You met me, Nemo.
Na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na.
Ba-do-do-do-do.
You met me, Nemo.
I'm not going to do it today.
No-no-no.
Na-na-na-na.
This is her solo song.
They each have solo songs too.
So it's fun.
Do they have Nia Peen on here?
Sorry.
Now I'm going down a rabbit hole.
Nia.
Maybe...
I think it's a small...
Nia.
No!
Panda Boy did the whole Nia Peen album.
Nia Peen is a...
is a...
duo idol group.
They're now disbanded.
But it was...
one of the members of Dempagumi, Pinky.
And another member of...
Dempagumi used to have a sister group called Moso Calibration.
And so the two of them, a member from Nia from Moso Calibration and Pinky from Dempagumi, made this little group.
And it's kind of a play on words because Nia Peen, Nier Pin, they were a golf themed group.
And Nia Peen is close to Nier... like the term for golf.
So it's kind of cute.
And all their songs are like...
They have one song called Nice Shot.
It's so fun.
All their songs are so great because they're Panda Boy.
Yeah.
Why golf?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
I don't know if they play golf or anything.
I think it's Nia Peen.
No, it's not.
Sorry.
It's...
Here, hold on.
Let me see if I can...
Oh my...
Yeah, yeah.
I was like, oh my gosh, wait, you're right.
No, that's...
I read it wrong.
No, it's a small...
It's a small...
Nia Peen.
Sorry to just call you wrong, but...
Sorry to call you wrong.
But they do have their songs on YouTube so you can listen to them.
They have a...
Their whole album is called Nice Shot and all the songs are really good.
I love Panda Boy.
If I could get a song by Panda Boy, I would die.
One of my favorites, probably my favorite on the album, I really like Have a Nice Shot.
I like Hazard Beat.
Hazard, hazard beat.
Hazard beat, hazard beat.
So good.
Here, let me show you this.
Let me show you the picture of them.
They're so cute.
Oh, gosh, they're so cute.
Hold on, I have to screenshot it though.
This is the album cover.
I got to go see them.
This group specifically, I got to go see them live.
So I have a checkie with Pinky.
This is them.
The one on the left is...
Well, okay, hold on.
Wait, this is confusing.
At the top, the one on the left is Pinky and the one on the right is Nia.
And then...
In the bigger picture, the one on the left is Nia and the one on the right is Pinky.
Yeah, they're so cute.
They're so cute.
So...
Even though they're not around anymore, I recommend their songs so much.
I recommend all songs of Dempo-related.
Dempo-relation.
Okay.
Hmm.
What haven't I sang that is a really popular Dempo song?
I could try Precious Summer, but I don't know if I can hit the notes at the end.
Baby, baby.
You mean Nia and Pinky.
Yeah.
Do you remember Pinky, Nora, Petra?
I do!
I do remember Pinope, Pinky, Nora, Petra.
Nia.
I do.
Hmm.
Did Future Diver...
Did Denden Passion...
Did Sakura Operation...
Dempo-gumi's version of Idol?
I don't think they have it on here.
I think I would have seen it if they had it.
Unfortunately, they don't.
It doesn't seem it.
It seems like they have it.
Oh, I don't know.
Oh, someone asked for Sabotage.
You know what?
I can do that one.
So this is actually a cover.
Okay.
This is kind of bad.
This is the only...
I don't know.
Like, this is...
I don't...
Okay.
This is a cover of Sabotage by the Beastie Boys, but I don't really know the...
I know this better than the original.
This might kill my throat.
Oh, gosh.
I mean, my throat's already dead.
Maybe I should have saved it for last.
Mini.
Nisachi.
Eitaso.
I don't know.
Moga.
Pinky.
Something.
What did I miss?
Here we go now.
Tiger.
Fire.
Cyber.
Fiber.
Diver.
Ja.
I can't stand it.
I know you planned it.
I've got to set it straight.
This water gate.
I can't stand rocking when I'm in here.
Because your crystal ball ain't so crystal clear so.
While you sit back and wonder why.
I got this fucking thorn in my throat.
Oh my, it's a mirage!
I'm telling y'all, it's sabotage!
So, so, so!
So listen up!
Cause you can't say nothing, nothing!
You'll shut me down with the push of your button button!
All right, I'm gone!
I'll tell you now, I'll keep it on and on!
I'm
trying to tell you now, it's sabotage!
You're against the world!
Listen all of y'all, it's a sabotage!
I don't remember what they say here.
You're scheming on a thing, that's sabotage!
Hahaha!
Yeah!
That was Denpokumi's version of sabotage!
By the Beastie Boys!
Yay!
It's so funny because when you look up, the cover for that is, first of all, so perfect.
Hold on, sabotage.
Denpokumi.
The cover of it is so awesome.
They have little mustaches and sunglasses on.
And when you look at the comments on the YouTube video of this, half the comments are like, Yo, this is awesome!
And half of them are just like, what the hell did I just watch?
Look at them, they're so cute!
Oh my gosh, they're so young.
Here, I'll show you.
These are not the... this is the older members.
This is like the six members that I talked about at the beginning of the stream.
Hold on, I need a cursor.
I need like a pointer.
Aren't they so cute?
Let's see.
One second.
Let's just use this one.
Save.
This one looks like a Mickey Mouse hand.
Don't sue me, Disney.
Oh, it's huge!
So this is my Kamiyoshi.
That's Nemu.
This is Moga.
This is Risa.
This is Mirin.
This is Pinky.
And this is Eitaso.
So, out of all of these members, these three are still in the group.
So Mirin, Risa, and Pinky.
Yeah.
So...
Nemu has shaped my entire life and existence.
This uniform, I have hanging up in my bedroom.
They sold them.
The artist is iMadonna.
She did a lot of work with them.
Um...
But it's their, like, anime versions of their faces.
I have this.
And actually, also, in my office, I have the Deerstage uniform hung up.
Because they also sold that before, too.
Um... so...
Yeah.
Like, everywhere, I have posters.
I have Denpagumi posters in my maid cafe.
Like...
I don't know.
I'm...
I'm Yume Minemu.
Please sing for me.
Uh...
Can I do it?
I'll think about it.
So everywhere in my maid cafe, I have Denpagumi stuff everywhere.
I see Denpagumi.
I think about Denpagumi every day.
So they're super duper important to me.
I don't know.
Hopefully... Hopefully...
Hopefully I'm conveying their strength.
Thank you for singing my favorite Beastie Boys song.
I'm glad!
I've always actually wanted to sing that before, so...
I'm really excited.
I'm really happy.
Um...
But yeah, hopefully I'm conveying how awesome they are.
It's hard to say without, like, just witnessing their power.
But they're truly...
Probably the best idols in the world.
I believe.
Um...
Let's see.
Going back to this...
Nagini...
Sabotage...
You had me at Otaku Girls.
They're so goofy.
They're just such a great group of people.
And honestly, just everyone at Dear Stage, too.
Because...
You know.
It's...
It's a lot of idol groups would probably not have someone get married and have a baby and still let them perform, you know, and at least, you know, I don't know a lot about the inside of Tear Stage, but I would like to believe that they treat the idols there very well.
I would think so.
This has been awesome.
You bring a lot of joy.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Which one is this one again?
Is that the...
No, that's...
There is Notobochi.
I don't think I'm ready for Orange Realm.
Actually, maybe I am since I just sang that and it was so goofy and funny.
There is Otsukaresama.
I don't think I can sing.
Otsukaresama.
It's too difficult.
It's so difficult.
This song is awesome.
Actually, the artist for Oyasumi Punpun did the art for this song, Ashita Chikyuu Ga Kona Gona Ni Nattemo.
It's a very popular song that like a lot of idols in different groups will cover.
So I'll sing it also.
It's kind of fast, but I'll do my best.
Asano?
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
But yeah, the music video for this is also really beautiful.
The music video for this is also really beautiful.
A little pause... and we are back.
A little pause...
and we are back.
A
little pause... and we are back.
Like, the last day on Earth.
What if the Earth, like, basically, like, ceases, like, uh, what's the word?
Um, um, like, breaks into pieces?
My favorite part of the line, or favorite part of the lyrics is just like, I'll just say, that sucks and die.
The lyrics just get longer and longer and longer.
Or the titles, rather.
Relatable, right?
Ah, so.
Yeah.
It's a, it's not a happy song.
It's kind of, it's kind of sad, but it's really pretty.
Wow, thank you!
Kind of weird, in a good way, watching my Kamiyoshi that I've watched graduate twice.
Twice?
Watch your Kamiyoshi graduate.
Glad we could be here to share the love and remember the good times.
Um.
Well, my Kamiyoshi already graduated.
But it is my Kamiyoshi group, so you're not entire, you're not wrong, you're not wrong.
Are you a time traveler?
Do you see me graduate the future again?
He watched the VOD twice.
Oh, got it, got it.
Hahaha.
Um, yes, I think I, MintPhantom, have only graduated once.
Yeah.
Ah.
L-Side Konguru.
Hahaha.
He re-zeroed.
Um.
Hahaha.
We change in the future.
Assistant.
Oh, yes!
Okay, this is the song I did want to sing, but...
It's really fast I just remembered.
Got everything just done?
Remember when to remember on on on the earth...
Do we really need Black ah?
White is black right?
Well,
because you said your favorite problem was the Kodami.
The same problem I remember.
Ha.
It's really really fast so I'm not going to try it.
I've already made a fool of myself.
I am curious about the medley, you know.
I think I'll try the medley.
.
I see what songs they include.
Oh, I have 40 minutes, okay.
Where'd the medley go?
Look, there's even a song called, Welcome to Deer Stage.
So awesome.
There's even a song called, Welcome to Deer Stage.
When they perform it, it's so cute.
They have one of the members put on some glasses and stuff.
And they like...
I wonder actually if this song is 7 minutes long.
Because it has a very long intro.
I wonder if they keep it.
I'm curious.
Let's try it.
Let's see what it's like.
Wait, what was the first one?
Die, die, die.
They put on glasses and go, Question?
Stop.
I arrived in time for Deer Stage.
Welcome to Deer Stage.
Oh!
This is the song that I...
I was like...
This music video?
Actually, I said Sakura Operation is my favorite music video?
No.
This song.
This song is my favorite music video.
Oh my gosh.
Nanryo Jundan.
And let's go.
Soshite Shi-chan, Ba-chan, Ka-chan, Do-chan, Nene-chan.
Ba-chan, Ka-chan, Do-chan, Nene-chan.
Naipo, Aibo, Da-da-na.
Dai-ha-ken-desu.
Bambande-n-ba.
Toba-shi-te-rui.
Iku-sei.
Achi-kochi-sochi.
Dochi-shibou-gato-dono.
Boku-ninaru ki-mochi.
Se-kai-ni-todoke.
The music video was like half animated.
Itsudatte!
Imadatte!
Imi-ndatte!
Moku-datte!
Dare-datte!
And then, it's so awesome.
We put together.
There's like...
Oh god.
It's the hardest songs.
Why?
Oh, no.
We're gonna have to like, Oh no...
This is the weirdest medley ever.
Chug, chug, chug chug Okay,
I can't do it anymore...
This is not even like...
a good medley.
This is not even a good medley.
Like they just I thought it would... you know how medleys tend to... the songs bleed into each other?
No, it just stops.
It just stops.
That was funny.
Let's see.
Have a half hour.
Wow, thanks Space Ghost!
Always love to have your singing on in the background while I do stuff.
Yeah, okay.
Oh gosh.
So...
You know, it's funny that Yoko brought up the graduations.
I thought if I ever graduate...
If I ever can do like a graduation concert...
I would want to sing Orange Realm.
Because to me it's such a special song too.
You know, it's a very special song to Denpogumi fans and...
And...
Like...
The whole...
Everyone changes their penlight...
There's no Orange member, right?
But everyone...
Well, there is now.
There used to not be.
But everyone changes their penlights to orange.
And...
It's just a really beautiful song.
And so...
Girl doesn't even remember.
I meant...
If I graduated a second time.
So...
Yeah, it's just a really pretty song.
And...
It's...
It's a good...
It's like...
A song like...
Just kind of like...
I'll never forget the memories here basically.
You know?
So...
I'm going to try and sing it and not cry.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
Don't sing it or you'll graduate.
No, I'm undoing the curse.
No,
I'm undoing the curse.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Oh, what's the...
Um...
Are you okay?
You don't know where my store?
I'm calling to you.
Orange day.
Magic and future.
Um...
The things we made together.
The love in my heart.
Hahaha.
Um...
Super Goobies!
When you're by my side.
My precious feelings.
I can't say anything anymore.
Every time our eyes meet.
My heart goes up.
I'll fly up, but you won't notice.
Don't change.
If you're dying on this same dream.
We're the same, even if it's not in color.
We're fated to stay together.
Forever.
Oh my gosh, I can't believe I can't remember the Orange Ria mix.
But I remember the Kira Kira tune one better.
A little pause... and we are back.
That was Orange Reum.
Wow, I can't believe I sung it without crying!
Yeah!
But I know when I do though, can I get a tune mix?
Oh gosh.
Orange Reum.
But I should probably start singing some of the sadder songs that I've been not wanting to do.
Because I'm gonna run out of time and then I won't be able to sing them at all.
Oops.
I have no keeny-eaty songs.
It's crying time.
I don't know if I wanna do... I'll do WWD best now.
And probably do Kira Kira tune last.
Let's do that now.
We can also do Otsukare Summer.
Oh, Precious Summer too.
WWD best.
Since we did WWD and WWD 2.
I have to go to the bathroom.
I have to go to the little ghosty's room.
It's all this tea I'm drinking.
Look how many composers, people involved for the lyrics and everything.
It's crazy.
You can hear, like, some of their past songs in it.
This way.
Uchiage hanabi ni furimuita Kakenuketa basho ni shikaketa yume Ikitekita koto imi wa attanda na Sukoshi dake jibun homete ii kana Modorenai senzei yori Kamisama jidai no naisei yori Kono sekai aishitetai Ano ne, owari nante konai te Waratte agenu Nanjuu oku nenbun no hajikou desu Nanjuu oku nenbun no hajikou desu
Chino soko wo okomete ita
Asha hashiri suzukenda It's a little too high for what my voice can do right now, but it's okay.
Zenryoku shisou kimi ni todoke Aenakunatte hashimete kizuku you na Omoide nande hoshiku nanda Otona ni natte ima demo ne Ashita ni natte ima demo ne Wasurenai Akirametakunai kimochi darake Dakara kyutto, chotto, kyutto, kyutto Chotto, chutto, aishite motto
Sekai juu terashite konna ni mo Mabushinda te utatte yaru Heda suku natte yuru Nokujyutsu Aishite motto Zutto, zutto, zutto, zutto Egaita mirai wa anna ni mo Azayaka da
Denpanet Issei ni hirogattara Wide, wide hitotsu ni natchai Live, live wa nikiteru atashisa Rakuten, rakuten, inken da Akiho no Noko, noko
Indaka shite oite ne Gatsun, gatsun Yukimashou Mada, mana
Oh...
It's hard to tell if you're like...
Not a super Denpa fan obviously If you don't know Denpa so much but like...
A lot of the lyrics kinda reference their old songs Or reference the members as you could see They even said Orange Realm Which is a song that I just sang And like...
The choreography for the dance too Like is a lot of...
A lot of...
Their old choreo and stuff The music video just references a lot of stuff too It's a...
It's one big love song to like...
Denpa Gumi and their fans so...
It's so awesome It's so awesome, it's so awesome And it's such a pretty song It's so fun and...
Yeah, you notice that?
Yeah!
Yippee I love Denpa End of an era for sure But they're legends so they're...
Their legacy will live on Because...
They've changed so much They've influenced so much so...
Um...
I know that...
Ah...
People will continue loving Denpa They said that their story is ending So I wonder...
If that means like a...
Like a...
Another group will come?
Maybe not Denpa Gumi Inc but...
Um...
What could be...
Electric...
Electric Gumi Company Something...
Yeah...
And I know...
I know...
Or...
Rather...
They...
All...
They all like...
Love Akiba so much And try to keep that spirit of Akiba alive too So I hope that...
Um...
That...
Uh...
Like...
That continues to...
Mmm...
Maybe become a Vtuber group Actually, Deerstage has a Vtuber group Called Deers Company...
No, sorry...
Gems Company Called Gems Company Um...
They're part of Deerstage And actually...
One of the ex-members of Denpa Gumi Nemotonagi Is a Vtuber So...
You can find her by her name Uh...
Nemotonagi She goes by the same name as her Vtuber self too So...
Mmm...
Yeah...
Gems Company is actually affiliated...
It's like...
A collaboration between...
Deerstage and...
Square Enix...
I believe...
So...
Um...
I didn't know that about Gems Company Yeah!
Deerstage is everywhere!
Isn't that crazy?
Itasa tried Vt...
Oh!
Yeah!
She did a little bit, right?
Mmm...
There's one Gems Company song that I love so much Uh...
Hold on...
Let me see if I can find it It's one of the solo songs It's not like a...
It's not like one of the group songs But...
Um...
It's one of the solo songs Uh...
If I were to ever make a song...
If I were to ever get my own original song...
Um...
Like a cool song...
I would reference this...
I would like...
Be like...
I want something like this...
Wait...
I can't remember...
It's so sad though...
I can't remember the name of it...
Cause I'm...
My brain is dumb...
Wait...
Um...
I've heard of Gems Company?
Yeah!
Yeah...
I'll find it later...
And I'll post it on...
Um...
On Twitter...
Yeah...
Or I'll post it in the comments or something...
Why can't I remember the name of it though?
Uh...
Oh!
I found it though!
I found it!
I just found the song actually...
I'll just post it here...
It's...
Shoujo...
Senso...
Paradox...
Okay...
Manifesting a Mint Ori song...
Hehe...
I'm sorry...
We'll see...
I don't know...
Hahaha...
We'll see...
I don't know...
Do an Akiba themed original song someday?
Maybe...
Hehe...
Maybe I can...
Get a Panda Boy...
Hahaha...
Hmm...
I don't know...
Yeah...
Well...
Um...
There was one group that I really...
Really loved also...
Um...
It was kind of when like...
I wasn't...
Like...
You know when...
Uh...
Sorry...
I keep saying like...
Um...
So...
After my Kamiyoshi graduated from Denpa...
It kind of was in like...
A mourning period...
So...
I ended up...
Um...
I obviously still supported them...
But I...
Uh...
Ended up falling for another group called Engaging...
Who was also a Dear Stage group...
And one of the...
My favorite member...
My favorite member of that group...
She...
She also loved Nemu...
Haha...
Nemu was her Oshi too...
So...
Um...
I have a Checky album...
Completely...
Um...
Completely full of just...
Checkies from Engaging...
Um...
They were so great...
And their music was all composed by...
Um...
A music artist that I love...
Mosaic Wave...
And so...
Um...
Uh...
Because it was Mosaic Wave and Dear Stage...
Together...
I was like...
This is...
This is my Kami group...
This is like the best group ever!
And then they ended up disbanding...
During...
The pandemic...
Haha...
So...
I...
Uh...
Um...
I've been...
It was...
Like...
For a long time...
I kind of stopped liking idols...
Um...
I focused...
A lot on Vtubers...
I kind of start...
Stopped liking...
Idols...
Because I was so...
Devastated by...
Losing them...
My...
My favorite member of the group...
Actually...
Ria...
Ria in Denpogumi...
Um...
She's one of the new members...
But she...
Came from Engaging...
And they also got another member from Engaging...
That went to Denpogumi...
Called...
Uh...
Her name's Ai...
Aizawa Kozue...
You might recognize her...
Because she's a really popular...
Um...
Dancer...
Uh...
Like on Nico Nico...
And stuff like that...
And so...
Um...
Uh...
They...
She...
But she graduated from the group...
Because...
Um...
She...
Had some health issues...
Unfortunately...
Um...
But Ria is still in the group...
And she was in Engaging...
Um...
She was a member of Engaging...
When they were around...
But my Kamiyoshi...
Well...
Not Kamiyoshi...
My Oshii from Engaging...
She...
Uh...
She basically like...
Left the internet...
So...
But...
Yesterday...
She posted...
She made a post on Instagram...
Because...
Because of the...
Denpogumi announcement...
So I was like...
My Oshii...
My...
Oshii posted...
Yeah...
I understand...
When my Oshii graduated...
I nearly stopped watching YouTubers...
Yeah...
I get it...
But...
Now...
I have some other idols...
That I really really love...
So...
And I still love Denpogumi...
And I will love them until...
Their very last day...
And beyond...
So...
Yeah...
Sometimes it just takes some time to...
Get back into...
But you...
You know...
Um...
You...
You know...
If you like something...
You don't have to...
Give it up...
Like for me...
I liked idols...
But it was hard to find...
Someone else...
To...
Support...
And everything...
Den Den passion till the end...
Exactly!
Luckily I found a certain maid...
You found another maid?
I missed the maid with the magic voice...
Stop it...
Gotta give yourself a grief period...
For some graduations...
Yeah...
Idols are very ephemeral...
They can be...
Right?
But...
With Denpogumi...
I've had them for so long...
I cannot...
I can only...
You know...
Obviously...
No matter how much time...
I had with them...
I would wish them off...
With a smile...
But...
I can only feel like this...
It feels right...
Prior to me...
It's just like...
I never thought this day would come...
But also...
I feel like...
They've been around for so long...
It's okay...
I'm gonna go grab...
Some more water...
And then...
Um...
I'm going to sing...
So gimme...
Just a second...
To go grab...
Some more water...
And then...
Oh...
I have to...
Wait...
Nevermind...
Oh my gosh...
I'm not going to go grab more water...
I'm going to sing...
Precious Summer!
I only have...
10 minutes...
Until my...
Karaoke subscription...
Expires...
Oh no...
Oh my gosh...
I don't think...
I can sing this one...
Very well...
Either...
But that's okay...
Let's go...
Z
E M P I...
TEPA GUMI E...
I'm
the best...
I'm the best...
I'll always protect a Flint ynd....
I...
I'm just bubbling all the lyrics to the song...
Yes Ho!
Ye
- Sorry I can't do it...
I'm TIRED...
This song is so fun though...
I know the song...
I know the calls...
I want to do the...
Are you feeling it?
Natsu...
Something...
Some
advice...
Hoshi hito!
Crimson fireph lovely...
I'm sorry I'm so out of breath.
I'm so tired.
I feel a pressure summer.
No, it's precious.
I felt the pressure there though.
Holy cow.
My brain just said, I don't think I'm gonna read anymore.
Oh my god.
No break time.
Wait, is this song really fast too?
They're all so fast!
I love the high energy of that one.
It's so fun!
It's one of my favorite newer songs that Denpa has put out.
I can't wait to listen to it.
I don't
know, bye bye.
Oh, this song!
The music video is so awesome because they sent the song into space with a weather balloon!
Oh my god, what is this katakana?
I can't wait to listen to it.
It's so cool!
Here we go again.
Oh, and our turn!
Okay, that's a lot.
What is this song?
Don't look at me!
I'm so surprised.
Oh, my god.
I don't know what's the title, but it's amazing.
That's the last one.
What?
It's amazing.
But that's all I can think about.
It's all I can think about.
I don't know.
All I want to do is hear you sing.
Cute gibberish.
My head is going crazy.
Oh my gosh.
I have 5 minutes left so...
I won't do evergreen.
I can save that for another day.
I think I said I would do Kirakirachun.
Last.
I didn't do Denparinai.
Oh, vandalism!
Wait, maybe I have time for both of these.
Maybe I have time for this one.
And for Kirakirachun.
I love this one.
Itsuka Haruka Kanatai.
This one is so pretty.
Maybe I'll do a short version of it.
I guess we need a part 2, maybe.
I'll do the short version of the second one.
And also, I want to do another one.
They are going to say its just a joke.
Let's do it.
A little pause...
and we are back.
Oh my god, I'm not gonna have enough time!
No!
My subscription!
I have to stop it early!
I wonder if it'll let me finish singing Kirakirachun.
Okay, sorry.
No, no!
Subscription!
My subscription!
Kirakirachun!
Kirakirararararara Kirakirararararararararararararararararararararar Kirakirakirakirakirakirakirakirakiratokirakirakira This song is so important to me!
I just wanna sing it!
Where are you Kirakirachun?
Kirakirakirra...
Where... oh!
Moment of truth.
Thank you for watching!
Thank you
for watching!
Thank you for watching!
I think I got that last one wrong.
I don't remember it.
Wait.
Rokunin?
Wait, I said Mutsu.
Wait, I don't remember.
Whatever, it's fine.
I got the other one.
I won't give up on my dream of that day!
Is the past gone now?
Let's see!
It should be, right?
What if it's not?
That would be so embarrassing.
I rushed to it.
I rushed to do it!
That is the last song.
And it makes 20 songs!
I want to do it!
Let's see...
Yeah!
There it is!
Tojiru.
Yep.
Cancel.
Oh wait, not cancel.
There we go.
Erase the yo-yaku.
I thought it might stop me mid-song, but it didn't!
I have to pee.
Oh, I'll leave this up so you can hear it.
I'll be right back.
Get some water.
And go to the bathroom.
BRB.
Tempogumi.
It's my Oshii group.
For more than a decade, too, it still doesn't feel real.
I know.
Your karaoke cheered me up a lot.
Thank you so much.
Thank you!
Oh, BRB.
BRB.
I'm back.
I'm back, everybody.
Cease.
Cease all activities.
Cease your activities.
I'm back.
Yippee!
20 songs of...
Well, basic... almost 20 songs.
Full Tempogumi ink power.
Did you guys feel the power of Tempogumi?
In fact, you only got the smallest fraction of Tempogumi's power.
They're the most powerful.
Thank you for the karaoke.
No, thank you!
I wanna see if they have a song on here real quick.
I wonder.
Even though this song doesn't...
Oh wait, you can't see anymore.
I'll keep it a secret.
Arigato, arigato.
Chuuu.
Arigato!
Ah.
Keep this song a secret.
Maybe I'll perform it in the future.
I always have wanted to perform this with a group of people though.
So, I think it's... the song does best as a group.
Oh, they do have it!
Oh, no they don't.
They don't have it!
So I can never sing it.
Never mind.
I can... I can't sing it.
In karaoke.
But maybe one day I can sing it.
Like on a stage.
But it's better as a group song.
It's also better as a live song.
Like the song itself is good but...
Hearing it...
Experiencing it live is way better.
Yeah.
So I used to...
Perform a little.
Actually, I don't want to listen to this music anymore.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna turn off this and we're gonna listen to...
Let's see.
What Dempagumi music can I put on?
Dempagumi...
Ah...
What's that?
What...
Um...
It's not MIDI.
Oh my gosh.
What's the...
Um...
The small...
The...
Not small.
Why can't I think of it?
Um...
There's so many more songs that I wanted to sing too.
But I would have messed up every single one of them.
So you know what?
It's okay.
Not lo-fi.
Not chiptune.
Um...
Like when it's a music box.
Music...
Oh...
Or...
Org...
Org -or...
Org-or...
Here we go.
I can just repeat this.
Oh.
This doesn't add.
Hold on.
Let me...
Children...
Waaaaaaaahhhhh...
OMG.
Oh my god, it was so fucking loud.
What even was that?
I exited out of it so fast I couldn't even tell.
That I just... I just went...
I exited out of it so fast it took me to eBay.
Where I was looking at Metal Gear items.
Okay, here we go.
This should be good now.
Hold on, I'm gonna turn it down so it doesn't jump scare me.
There we go.
eBay jump scare.
I found these cute little patches of Kero-tan.
Yeah.
What was I saying before that?
Don't make me cry.
Oh yeah, something about performing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I used to perform a little bit.
Um...
And uh...
And um...
I would always sing Kirakirachun.
The old...
Yeah, cause I was talking about the song that I wanted to sing with a group of people.
Um...
When I would perform a little bit...
I would kinda go crazy.
Like...
Um...
Like, I'm the type that like feels the music, you know?
So like...
Um...
Like...
Stage diving...
Or rolling on the ground...
Or like climbing things...
Is nothing new to me.
But...
Um...
Not that I had like a huge enough crowd to stage dive into.
But...
Stuff similar like that...
We know you'd go crazy.
That goes without saying.
It's one of the...
Sad...
Um...
The sad...
Things about being a VTuber is that, you know, I'm stuck here digitally.
So...
I can never perform that well.
I can never get away with you guys.
But that's okay.
Just a little bit maybe.
Is that how you died?
I dunno.
Hmm...
Imagining Mint in a mosh pit?
Yeah!
I did!
There is some like um...
I very distinctly remember being in a mosh pit for an idol group called Passcode.
I didn't realize this was so short.
Hold on.
Denpa Gumi...
Maybe we don't do... let's see what other ones they have.
They have...
Oh, they have WW... wait, that one's even shorter.
Oh, this one's a whole playlist.
You guys, I've got a bit of a wild streak about me.
But I think it's just because I like passion.
And I like... so, you know, I find that...
That in like...
In like...
Idols like that or something, you'll get a lot of passionate, crazy things.
Like, you know, I don't care if they spit on me.
They're feeling it in the moment, you know?
Just throw the monitor in the crowd.
We get it.
Building you a robot body to stage dive with boss.
Oh my gosh.
Yay!
What are moshpets if not a big moment of passion?
Exactly!
I hope though you guys really like the karaoke.
Not all Vtubers play by that rule.
You're your own boss now.
Do what you like.
I like... I like being Vtuber.
I like being... on the screen.
So... that is...
That is where you'll see me.
Unless they build a robot.
Which someone said they're already working on it right now.
So...
I hope... I'll... I want it.
This is one of the songs I didn't sing, but this is the one that I...
That is my Kamiyoshi's graduation.
Make you a Gundam.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
Can you imagine a Gundam jumping?
It would have to be made of like cardboard.
If it's too heavy...
You'll be a robot at Ofukai.
We can carry you.
Yes!
But I'm borrowing Vshojo's tech for that, so I don't know if they'll be very happy about that.
Dan, thank you for the 20 gifted!
Thank you!
You definitely could have virtually stave-dived yesterday.
I wonder if they could strap a camera on a daki.
That'd be awesome!
So excited to see you at Ofukai.
Me too!
I for once welcome our Mecha Mint Overlord.
Nanananananananana!
Chichi!
Pui!
This song, I only got to see...
No!
I got to see it live twice.
I got to see it in my last Japan trip.
I was so happy!
Oh my gosh, I was so happy to see Denpa last Japan trip.
I was...
It was so awesome.
It was just a mini live, so they only did a few songs, but...
But the first time I saw them ever was a release event.
Which is when they like, you know...
It is what it sounds like when they release a...
An album or a single.
In that case, it was an album.
And I got to take a cheki, my one and only cheki with my Kamiyoshi.
And um...
But I got to see them.
I could barely see them because I was way in the back and I...
Um...
I...
Uh...
There were many tall people around, but I could still feel their energy, so it was really great.
This was my first time hearing these songs with this group.
I love that it was more than just a karaoke, but stories about them as well.
Really got through how cool they were.
I'm glad!
I'm so happy!
Was the first time you saw them the six-person group?
Yes!
Yes, so it was still the six of them.
Um...
I never...
I'll be honest, I didn't even know about Denpa Gumi when they were a five-person group, so...
I got into them when they were a six-person group.
Around...
This is another Psyche K song.
When did...
Let's see...
Den Den Passion came out...
2013!
So!
I've known about them for...
For...
For over a decade!
I've been a fan!
Wow!
Yeah...
It's just a little bit over a decade.
So...
It's sad that I couldn't be around for all 16 years, but...
That's okay.
I still got to...
See them for...
Or, like, follow them for so long.
And...
Maybe later I can post some...
Pictures of, like, my...
Ina bag...
And...
It's double-sided.
Back in the day, too, I used to be, like...
Not involved with Japanese fans, but...
I would talk with a few, and...
I had one...
One person drew some...
Nemu...
Badges and stuff.
And...
And they sent them to me.
They...
Because I couldn't go to the event, so...
Should have gone with a tall, strong friend to climb on their shoulders.
I wish!
The...
Oh!
Another time...
Was...
That I saw Denpagumi...
Was also...
It was at Tokyo Idol Festival.
And I waited...
I waited about 8 hours...
In line...
Like, in the venue...
To get to the very front.
And I saw them...
Front row!
I got to see Denpagumi!
So...
It was...
It was a...
I, like...
Packed calorie mate...
In my bag...
And, like...
When I got hungry...
I would...
I would, like...
Bend down...
And I would...
Munch and munch and munch...
And then I would...
Stand back up...
And cheer for the other groups...
That were performing...
And then, eventually...
I scooted myself to the very, very front row...
And it was so...
8 hours...
Yeah!
Yeah...
I waited...
I was, like...
So determined...
Um...
So...
Ah!
It was so awesome...
And, um...
It was tiring...
I mean, like...
Because...
There was, like...
It was just so much energy...
Like...
Because...
From so many groups...
Um...
But...
It was a...
It was...
Honestly...
I would do it again in a heartbeat...
And, um...
Nanana...
Did I sing this one?
No, I wanted to sing this one...
This one's...
Kitto Kitto Ne!
Nanana...
But, um...
Uh...
Yeah...
So, I saw them then...
I saw them...
Last trip...
So, that's three...
And then, I saw my Kami Oshi...
I saw my Kami Oshi perform...
In her, like...
Thing...
It was...
There were some Denpa members there, too...
But...
The Denpa-gubin didn't perform...
At that time...
So, that's four times...
Um...
Four times, I got to see...
Them, basically...
Thank you for introducing me to all these Denpa-gumi songs...
Wish I knew of them earlier...
But, definitely gonna dive into the rabbit hole tonight...
Yeah...
So...
Um...
Every...
Every time before...
Like...
I just...
You know...
It's...
It's expensive...
So...
Couldn't...
Uh...
Go...
But, that's okay...
Um...
Still got to see them...
And...
You know...
Sometimes, some people never get to see...
Their...
Favorite idols...
Live...
Or anything...
So...
I...
Um...
Very lucky...
This was a nice karaoke to wake up to!
I always love seeing your passion for idols!
I wish Denpa-gumi idols and fans...
Nothing but the best!
Thanks, Chilliaks!
Are you still in Japan?
Go to Deer Stage!
Um...
Thank you!
Thank you for introducing me to Denpa-gumi Inc!
This was a beautiful stream...
Thank you for singing with...
For us today...
Thank you...
Yeah...
Actually, another idol that I really love...
Her name is Aonya...
She was a part of...
Um...
She was a part of Denpa for a little bit...
But now, she's a part of Arcana Project...
I'm in Yokohama right now...
Hahaha...
What is this one?
Oh...
Phantom of the Kill...
I actually don't...
Um...
Know this one as well...
I got to see Arcana Project in Shizuoka a little while ago...
It was pretty fun...
They're so great...
They're power...
They're like a...
Vocal powerhouse...
How do places like Deer Stage work?
You do just go there, get a ticket, and go inside?
Um...
I would first check the Twitter, because some...
Some...
Uh...
Dates are...
Are ticketed, so you can't go...
But, uh...
Typically...
Um...
If it's like...
But there are also special events where you can...
Um...
Still...
Just go...
Um...
But it...
Like on their Twitter...
On the Deer Stage Twitter...
It says...
Like...
They get...
They post a schedule for the week...
And it says if it's um...
Ticketed or not...
Um...
But uh...
But you can go...
You can go...
And um...
Uh...
Basically...
So...
The base...
There's three floors...
The base floor...
Is...
Uh...
Is the theater...
So...
You can pay a thousand yen...
Just to watch the show...
They do...
About three shows...
Um...
A night...
The second floor...
Is a cafe...
Um...
If there's no one...
If you wanna watch a show...
And there's no one around...
On the first floor...
Go to the second floor...
And say like...
Oh...
You can either go and stay at the cafe...
Or you can be like...
I...
Uh...
Um...
I want to watch the show on the first floor...
And you can just pay your thousand yen...
And then...
You can leave and come back too...
Um...
So if you're just like...
I'm gonna...
Gonna go and like...
Get...
Uh...
Some food at the konbini across the street...
You can go do that...
Um...
But uh...
And then the third floor is the bar...
Um...
And uh...
I...
Believe...
Each...
Each floor...
The...
Um...
The cafe...
And the...
The bar...
Both have...
Service fees...
Oh...
This is not bocce...
Yeah.
Starco Bomb is right by the...
Right down the street too.
So...
Yeah.
Thank you for introducing me to all these Dempa songs.
Definitely keen to listen to more.
Amazing karaoke mint...
Sorry if I didn't do them justice...
But...
Nananana nanana...
Nanananana nanana...
I was part of a nine-man raid on Deerstage before FES.
We kind of overwhelmed the girls but it was a great time!
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
Oh my gosh, you guys are crazy!
Yeah, when I've gone past a couple times, they're just like, Wow, there's so many more foreigners coming recently.
And I'm just like, really?
I wonder why.
But it's great.
I'm glad that more people are going to Deer Stage.
Especially with Denpogumi disbanding, I'm really worried.
But they do have some other popular groups in collaboration with another company called Perfect Music.
So right now you see DSPM, it means Deer Stage Perfect Music.
But I am still kind of... I am a little worried.
They survived the pandemic, which was so awesome.
I'm so grateful for that.
I think...
It's like the perfect place to experience true Akiba culture as it is now.
Oh my gosh!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
I love all your art.
Thank you!
I do...
I've ordered...
I haven't ordered since...
Engaging had broken up.
I had stopped ordering a bunch of stuff.
But...
I ordered some Aonion stuff when she was in Denpogumi.
And I ordered some of her stuff too.
As Arcana and other groups that I like.
So...
No,
not this song!
But...
Yeah...
It's weird to like, you know, be so sad when they've been around for so long.
But...
Aonion is very squished cheeks.
I really like Kyurushite from Deer Stage.
Yes!
Kyurushite is one of their like really popular groups right now.
So...
Kyurushite is very popular.
So that's why I'm like not entirely worried.
But, you know...
I don't know.
I still want them to do well.
And...
They've like...
There have been some groups that like formed and then disbanded shortly after.
So...
You know...
Just stuff like that.
Not weird at all?
I feel the Aonion fairies.
I hope we don't lose any more Akiba culture.
Me too.
Yeah...
Especially, you know...
Tenpa really kept the Akiba culture alive for me.
It's not dying.
It's not dead.
You know, Tenpa's legacy will be around.
But...
I think...
Uhhh...
Uhh...
I have like some other...
Like, more personal things about them disbanding too.
This is like very much end of a era.
I had a friend that she...
And I loved Tenpa together.
And...
You know...
She...
Uhh...
Just...
She was not a ghost and unfortunately she passed away last year and so I kind of will be thinking of her and everything.
So I thought of her a lot with the disbandment.
This was fun!
Thank you guys for even being here.
Thank you for indulging me in this
selfish karaoke of mine.
Definitely check out the songs that I sang and more.
They have so many more amazing songs that I didn't even touch.
I recommend, like I said, they have an album if you want to check it out.
Like a base kind of... base to follow.
The WWDBest has all their initial bangers and they have so many more good songs.
Oh!
I was going to share my... I didn't finish my schedule.
Oh no!
I didn't finish my schedule for this week, you guys, but I can give you a preview.
I can give you a preview.
So tomorrow, as usual... hold on, let me do this.
Screenshot.
And the times... oh wait, the times aren't right either.
Oh no!
Okay, I'm...
Okay, I'm only going to show you...
I'm only going to show you what's on the days.
And what streams I have.
Ignore the times!
In fact, I'm just going to cross them out.
I'm going to cross them out.
I'll fix them later.
I have actual times.
I'll post it.
I've got to finish my schedule.
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no.
Sorry.
Zombina!
I love this song so much.
They have like a Christmas theme song and a...
And a Halloween song.
And this is the Halloween one.
Zombina!
Okay, so...
Of course, Monday is Mintara Monday.
So the podcast will be released and I won't be streaming.
But Tuesday, I have a Helldivers 2 collab.
With Mintara, Hanyu, and Haruka!
Woo!
And maybe only I'm watching you for a few weeks.
I can already tell you're the best when talking about the things you love.
You're a good boy!
Thank you for...
Thank you!
Thank you.
Thank you for...
I don't know why...
I'm compelled to say this.
But thank you for...
Sending...
Um...
Sending your message...
When I can actually read it.
I don't know why I feel compelled to say that.
Thank you so much for the Aka Silva!
Thank you.
But yeah, I'm collabing with Mintara, Hanyu, and Haruka.
On Tuesday.
Wednesday is Bunny Garden.
Which is a...
The newest Q-Rate game.
Which, if you guys don't know Q-Rate, I love Q-Rate.
Oh my gosh, I love their games so much.
They have like...
There's another game I want to play by them called Maid of the Dead.
Which just...
Sounds perfect for me, right?
It's a zombie...
Um...
Oh, not zombie.
A vampire survivor type game.
Um...
But yeah, Q-Rate...
Hold on, let me...
Q...
Oh, no.
Um...
Bunny...
Bunny Garden.
Where is it?
Whoa.
Bunny?
Why isn't it showing up?
Uh-oh.
It was...
Wait, why isn't any of the Q-Rate stuff showing up?
Um...
But also...
They did like...
Some spooky like...
Escape from Izanami Hotel and things like that.
Um...
I was wondering when HENYA collab was gonna happen.
Don't worry!
We still plan on collabing.
I'm still working on it.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
I'm working on it.
Your Steam is not set to show adult games?
No, I saw it earlier.
I'm gonna...
Maid of the Dead.
Okay.
If I search it...
Okay, there's Bunny Garden.
And, um...
Thursday, I'm still deciding what I wanna do.
Friday, we're going to do a tour of Akihabara!
Yippee!
So...
Um...
So, if you're curious more about Deer Stage and Akihabara in general, I'll show you, um...
Some places that I go to and frequent and...
Well, not frequent, but you know...
Um...
So...
We'll do an Akiba tour on Friday.
Um...
Saturday, I will be out haunting.
And Sunday...
Um...
I haven't decided what I'm doing yet.
So...
Um...
That is...
That is the...
The...
Week...
Ish.
Oh my gosh.
I've been blushing this whole time.
Take care!
This is from, uh...
Gudugudu Fairies.
Oh my gosh.
Gotta do my first trip to Japan back at the end of March, but sadly didn't get to spend much time exploring Akiba.
Next time!
Yeah!
Akiba!
Next time!
Thank you for the very best!
So fun!
My passion at karaoke!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
Yeah...
So...
Um...
The streams might be shorter this week.
Just for some of them, like maybe...
Thursday and Sunday will be shorter...
Short, short streams.
So that I have more time to rest my voice, but since I didn't stream so much this week, this past week, I wanted to, uh...
Stream a little bit more.
So...
HMMMM....
Yes.
Okie dokie.
A few things left to say.
Considering that you aren't in Japan anymore, is it perhaps with HiGuy?
No, it's just gonna be on Google Maps.
Nothing so fancy like an actual tour tour.
Maybe one day I can do that with you guys, but...
But I... I mean, not me.
I wouldn't be doing it.
Maybe like someone leads around and I say like, Hey, go here!
Hey, go here!
But for this, I will be showing you through Google Maps and showing you some places, so...
Yeah, sorry.
Sorry that it's not...
Not...
Actually...
Me there.
That's a good idea!
I'm gonna set it up.
I do now!
With...
EyeTracker...
We can have the EyeTracker for the bunny garden, yeah.
Halloween Akiba Ghost Tours.
Just possess a made tour guide.
Perfect.
Also, love the profile picture, CurryNinja.
Thank you!
Thanks for introducing me to Denpugumi!
Hopefully, my information wasn't like all over the place.
Hopefully, you guys got a good...
Good...
Good idea about them, but...
Yeah!
You probably already know that, but in Google Maps, you can also time travel.
You can!
And I'll figure out what I'm doing Thursday and Sunday and finish my schedule and have it up maybe tonight or tomorrow.
For now, I'm gonna go eat.
And...
Yes.
Is there going to be a quiz?
Absolutely.
So happy I got to see them at AX 2016.
I...
Oh, I regret!
I regret it every day of my life!
After life!
Part of the reason I can't move on.
It's one of my regrets.
It's not...
Not seeing Denpa at AX in 2016.
You can get a buddy to walk around with a video camera for you or wherever you want, perhaps.
Yeah, I don't really...
No.
I can...
I will figure something out.
Yeah, thank you guys!
Thank you!
Regret.
Real.
Thank you!
Thank you, Boston!
And I will see you guys on Tuesday for Helldivers 2!
Okay.
Bustin' song today?
I'm going to leave it just Denpa songs today.
So sorry.
Sorry, but we're sticking with the Denpa theme.
But yeah.
I'm going to go eat.
You guys rest too.
Have a great rest.
Have a great Monday.
Listen to Mint and Mataro's summer special.
Yeah.
Bustin' Denpa cover.
Okay.
Bye.
Bye bye everyone.
Thank you.
Bye bye.
See you.
Thank you guys.
Thank you so much.
Bye.
Inku.
Denpa Gumi.
Bye bye.